hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge von
ich bin schon im spiel und habe das rad
nicht eingeblendet ich hab mir gedacht
das ganze beim ersten mal so gut ankam
spielt das hier einfach noch mal und ich
bin ein ball falls wir das spiel noch
nicht kennt in dem spiel geht es darum
dass ich hier quasi einfach so ein ding
machen kann und in diesen dingen kann
ich jetzt verschiedene kreaturen war
nicht zeigt euch das mal ganz kurz
mein gott ist lebt schon alter so bewegt
sich das was soll das und wenn ich
letztendlich wieder hier rausgehen haben
wir das ganze zum leben erweckt was das
sein soll weiß ich jetzt nicht
eigentlich sollte das da oben der kopf
seien allerdings hat der schwanz dann
irgendwie denn die überhand genommen
wir können hier auf jeden fall
irgendwelche teile bauen und dann haben
wir spaß
was ist das für larry bevor wir
allerdings damit anfangen muss ich euch
sagen dass ich
was wollte ich sagen ich habe keine
ahnung woran es genau liegt aber heute
ist der achte und wir haben bisher nur
sechs türchen aufgemacht deswegen machen
wir jetzt natürlich in sieben auch
hinter türchen verbirgt sich
warum ist er dann immer nur so scheiße
darin meine lieben freunde das ist eine
handtasche hier eine handtasche und eine
kiste voll mit schmuck ferrari an damit
die sich dann mal hübsch machen kann
das ist jetzt nicht wahr
meine nachbarn fangen an zu bauen um 17
uhr einer der meist geschriebenen
kommentare beim letzten video war luca
baut auf einen hähne und na klar also
warum nicht
hab ich mir gedacht und schaltet ab wir
tun ja auch noch gegen die wand schaltet
am besten ab wenn ihr keinen bock auf
dummheit und auf klopfenden nachbarn
habt ich hier wisst ihr ganzen tag brav
gechillt weil ein praktikum gewesen
schön gearbeitet kommt nach hause denkt
wir ja jetzt vor allem noch im video
aufnehmen alles schön gediegen namen
kommen die nachbarn klopfen wollen ich
meine ich hab ja nichts dagegen wenn man
denkt ja hier
naja ok es gibt immer was zu tun aber es
gibt nicht jeden tag was zu tun was habe
ich getan
kann ich das irgendwie rückgängig machen
am anfang einfach wieder von vorne an
ich wollte vorhin wirklich stark auf
details achten habe ich jetzt ist mir
ehrlich gesagt komplett egal ich will
einfach nur das was mache ich was mache
ich was es kann nicht sein immer wenn
ich irgendwas baufeld 18 sekunden schon
land zu leben und bewegt sich wieder im
dunkel bleibt stehen ich will hört auf
zu bauen
seid ihr bereit für den moment der
wahrheit dass man sehen kann wie der p
wer war das da hinten eigentlich nochmal
der penis hund ist fertig
was habe ich getan
obwohl ist schon harter krippe wenn
jetzt einige dass mein penis so aussieht
wie er hier ist man was macht die denn
da das ist doch echt magst du mich ist
nicht etwa der peene gerade auf haha ich
hab ihn ausgetrickst
wir müssen ein ebenbürtiges monster
bauen nein jetzt gibt die da hinten zu
suchen kennen also wenn das hier fertig
ist denkt sich pini auch nur so hätte
ich lud man besser nie angegriffen
was tust du da auch wenn ihr euch fragt
wie ein ganz normaler tag im leben von
luca aussieht davon läuft
da hinten steht zu sehen und ich gehe
ihr gas sie zusammen mit john schlange
tram
wir brauchen bessere namen ich nenne ihn
einfach nur donald hennie mich
vielleicht noch mal an dass ihr noch mal
wenn du donald ihn donald oh mein gott
jetzt habe ich beinahe an der leine ihr
müsst mal hier
doch kämpft kämpft los führte penny ach
das war ja gar nichts zu sehen
das ist ja diese komische andere mit
gestellt die wir zu beginn gebaut haben
heldt will mir doch einfach mit donald
ist viel zu groß
er kann mich gar nicht treffen ich würde
sagen das ist das jetzt auch schon
wieder mit der heutigen folge chn war
werden euch das video gefallen hat würde
ich mich über eine bewertung von wollt
ihr mehr chk ändern schreibt der sachen
die ich bauen soll in die kommentare
donald
du hast das letzte wort das war auf
jeden fall ein schönes letztes wort